all right this is our real thoughts on
osmosis jones which after seeing the
establish create 40 we're doing this
week i have nothing but praise for this
movie uh i'm not i'm not gonna say what
we're reviewing this I have a summer
cold but it was pretty tough to get
there so yeah but it uh but but but even
before seeing this piece of shit uh
osmosis jones honestly with the
exception of the live-action stuff it
almost works um it I can't here just
where did you get that something if you
take the live-action stuff out of it
it's not that bad of a movie yeah it
works in a kind of teenage Magic School
Bus kind of way like yeah and some of
the jokes actually are clever some of
the you know environments are clever in
the designs and stuff like animation
isn't bad I don't anime this one was
interesting I didn't and hate Chris Rock
as samosa I don't know any ia but I need
the voice cast yeah I mean the anger is
really around uh but the big thing for
me like okay we'll get to all the
live-action shit in a minute but just
the animation part itself which was done
by different people I tried emphasize
that in the review um is that for me the
big thing that dragged it down was the
cop cliches which is like okay forget me
the cop cliches have fun with them go
goofy go really big or mock them or
whatever but uh Murray
they didn't bother me as much as they
bother you I will say this if you're
going to do it then have more fun with
it ya know I felt like they kind of just
was like mushy I felt like they were
kind of just saying here's a bunch of
cop cliches but they didn't do anything
with it yeah it's like they weren't like
hey and here's how we're making fun of
it or here's how we're doing something
different I know when he's gonna mope
and dope because he's kicked off the
case he's gonna mope and dope and he has
to convince the partner to come back and
it's none of it's funny nah it's no
nothing's creative about it I yeah I
guess it just it didn't bother me all
that much but maybe that's because the
live-action stuff was so terrible that's
catchy from that's the cop who Shay's in
the animation I thought we're godsend
like by comparison
no this is what I feel like some people
are saying that there there's a fanbase
for what doesn't shock me honestly III
could now if you try to tell me you love
the live-action portions of this I'm
gonna have to be like wha but if you
tell me like the movie overall as a
whole and thought is an interest yeah I
got my Shack uh yeah cuz the animation
is the best thing about it by far uh one
even the creativity behind it I mean
there's a lot of jokes in the background
in the foreground and Sami it's clever
well it's kind of a poor man's gritty
Magic School Bus
yeah and I always loved the idea of like
being shrunk down and going inside like
a human body kind of like Fantastic
Voyage or something so well I liked a
little like piece in the middle ear the
little our founder and it's a sperm and
stuff like that it's legitimately clever
stuff yeah like I say it's when you have
to get to like the actual story what you
even have the story just of this disease
trying to kill you know the city of
Frank which I mean that that's funny too
you know they talk about Frank like he's
a city um you know is the helmet why
would it need to them that Frank is the
planet to considering the Sun no because
there's other like if they can transfer
to different parts and people and stuff
like that that went crazy a country I
just feel like given his size maybe not
in active Big Bertha there would be like
various cities in Frank gonna Bob's
Burgers moment oh my god why am i
analyzing this uh and with your cold you
can do that boys a lot better um but uh
yeah look take this out it it's one of
those movies where it's like watching it
I was like I'm almost liking it yet to
get through a few painful puns but Eliza
the big thing for me maybe took up a lot
of pasta was the puns were lame but they
were mostly similar that we're so glad
there is some that were
they're mostly harm was the only time
where I started just flipping my shit is
really kidney Rock my god yeah I know
and it's really rocky in this fucking
movie come on ya know they like that
shit was painful but no I take it back
that shit was nothing compared to the
live-action stuff that the farmer is
directing the farmers but not much if
any connection to the animated stuff at
all and it shows when you cut back and
forth and the original connection in
tone between these no and the the
original concept I guess was um it was
gonna be something like five to ten
minutes tops of live-action um and yeah
then the fairly fairly whatever brothers
got involved and from there it ballooned
into this whole other giant movie
because I'm so shortly after there's
something about Mary and they were a big
name by then I think oh yeah I guess
this would have been though it was like
two movies after there's something about
Mary I think you know I took a look at
meals and yeah if you look at like the
original draft and idea it's like it
would have been mostly animation five to
10 minutes of live-action and I still
don't think given what we got on screen
with the animated stuff it would have
been a great movie but it would have
been good and a hell of a lot better
than this because just when you're
getting into the animated stuff it keeps
cutting back to Bill Murray popping a
zit or some shit yeah and really
unlikable I mean like that there's the
looser bomb whatever trying to get life
back together he is so annoying and
unlikable in this movie and I love Bill
Murray I mean it's what my favorite kind
watch and I go Murray's 1yk read have
been comedic actors and I I just so
miserable to watch it and I don't even
get where they were going like the whole
backstory about osmosis jones and not
being able to defeat the bacteria and
the oysters or whatever that made him
barf I'm Molly Shannon I'm like so was
he normal before that and if so why is
he so insanely
sloppy now like there's none of it made
sense ya know and you can like always
slob II was
like no like they showed him is like
this you know you know pretty like
successful guy is like a suit and
everything and he's he's charming and
everything but then as soon as he does
that thing repeats in the woman which
don't get me wrong I mean I can see that
having effect for a while but I need to
just drama your live and he was a nobody
in the fully before that two minutes of
Bill Murray acting more normal at the
science fair this more interesting that
all of Bill Murray and the rest of this
movie yeah um so I don't know if you're
gonna do that I don't know why they
didn't just make him Bill Murray
honestly this movie may have been
funnier vivaz if his name was Bill and
it was just supposed to be Bill Murray
ya know like keep going while Hollywood
event or something like a leaky doesn't
ransom I do like what they did with that
doesn't dream himself well like well I
guess you could do that at court did a
kids with a little pig snorting lines ah
man the drunks are messing up the city
bill but I wasn't the big thing that
yeah we were noticing watching it which
is like I mean I don't know it's pretty
hard to argue was how much of this made
it into inside out I need especially the
circular room where they're talking the
microphone controlling his thoughts on
me I'm just like whoa this is getting a
little weird about you the dreams and
the subconscious inside me it's one of
those things are like okay I and it goes
around I Futurama
the Futurama episode with the worms
building a civilization and Fry's gut I
think came out the same year as a
samosas jail yeah I mean that happens
the whole point I think is that it
doesn't matter where the ideas come from
it's how you exit yeah when you do it
obviously inside out executed it well
and this not as much yeah well you have
a door they did a chance at the end more
time to develop the animated parts but
yeah like should you have to keep coming
back to that bullshit like oh yeah I sue
I think it had some good ideas I think
it had you know and again there's stuff
to admire about acting when we were
filming this Tamara was like okay just
for the record I really like this movie
and really not unfair now we're seeing
the cartoon spy really the live action
was pretty bad though right
everyone's in agreement with that she's
like yeah action so can you imagine if
you had taken it out you would have had
more time you would have Thrax would
have been a more interesting villain you
would have yeah that's a cool point for
assessment voice yeah and I'm like this
guy would be bad and he's a disease his
goal is to kill him and then he's like
and then next I'm gonna go for his
daughter and then all these I'm like
this is fucked up yeah this is like this
could be a cool quiz it'll be a great
villain but there's no time to really
develop him um same thing with us Moses
Jones they do their backstory but it
doesn't really make much you barely see
him in the band I even sure really how
he very I dunno not apparently like some
of osmosis jones like his family or
something was sucked out in a blood test
or something
like said and I'm like yeah like that
would have been amazing like there's all
this stuff you could have had any
animated part of the story that they
didn't do because you had to keep
cutting to Farrelly Brothers bullshit
and I mean it's bullshit it's not even
it's like grade F comedy stylings it's
not even like and I like there's
something about Mary I like parts of
that I like this is in yeah but even on
there even on some of their lower movie
levels this is about as
bottom-of-the-barrel as it gets for me
I'm like I can't say because I have not
seen their more popularly hated couple
movies except maybe done with number two
which I didn't eat um but yeah there are
so well in that the acting just like
well back when your mother
you know your mama de nada oh god rest
her soul remember then dies she's got to
exact hold no I hope I'm like what I
can't it might is this supposed to be an
emotional scene is he just being a
jackass and then at the end like shit I
feel terrible saying but she's so
heartbroken over visit I'm just like
really kid he might be better off like
it is he's just such a uh he's so
unlikable um yeah and I didn't feel any
sympathy because of that and I'm like
he's dying she's all upset I'm like if I
felt any sympathy for this character
like this would be an upsetting scene
but it's not cuz I just I want just
please die you know gross-out humor is
not impossible to make funny but in my
opinion I think about everything oh well
it is so difficult to do cuz a lot of it
just involves around you grow we said
there's not much pain involved and tell
me like psychological or physical pain
is much funnier than Oh covered in
something Ness far been seen was
ridiculous
the the zit seen was ridiculous for me
though for some reason where I loses
when he brings his foot up at the table
at the seafood breast are you - I'm like
who did ya and I'm in the because he
barked at the science fair I guess valya
now he does this I mean it makes no
sense and how you know it's I know
they're going for a joke when they say
like that he lost his job at the pea
soup factory okay I get it cuz what keep
you to look like green soup and feed pea
soup and people can be like oh he's like
saying something or whatever a bad image
but then you have to go to the
sentimental the heartfelt stuff it's
like this makes no sense why he would go
from a piece of factory to cleaning
elephants and it's funny reading the
interviews it goes like some of the
people on the animation side were like
oh and the families are bringing so much
to this story and this is bad and I
can't tell if like they were serious or
if this is like the studio made them to
say that for Stockholm Syndrome they
just were so taken by chakra like well I
guess it's gotta turn out good right
like you know but it's very much had
this PR kind of feel to it like oh we're
so grateful to them aren't we yes yes
right and so tough because I think the
Farley brothers can do both really good
comedy and sentimental stuff like
kingpin I thought like was legitimately
kind of like you know sentimental and
nice and even elements of there's some
About Mary uh so there is you know you
can feel for their characters but it is
so rare that it happens um I haven't
seen a really good film from them in a
long time like I've got to go back to
those originals like kingpin Something
About Mary even dumb with numbers just
dumb but I mean it's at least is mildly
amusing
housing dumb at number two is like
pretty much what you think it is it's a
sequel and it's dumb but I think like I
didn't mind it but if people hate it I
totally understand but it's like
you gonna see that movie don't act like
the first ones a classic don't do that
don't act like one in the first one they
got it right stupid I love it
but it's stupid I just feel bad for the
animation team which is why yeah I
didn't want to talk much in particularly
the review like we kind of don't address
them as much because I don't want to
drag them down yeah with the live-action
part like really most of what sucked was
the live-action something no thing I
will say is I had this watching it there
is something about the animation on
Jones in particular that he always has
this weird sick grin going the build
your smile yeah yeah it's like this
creepy kind of rape faces I think it's
like yeah
if you positive random moments in this
film you'll find so many moments where
it looks like he's doing something
inappropriate yeah which I'm sure was
part of like kind of like the gritty
feel they were trying to go for a little
bit and if I came off as we're
particularly cuz he's got that row of
like perfect teeth in like yeah but a
kid sees gums a lot of times yeah
everything so it's like it what if that
okay if it if you was more like a
beautiful I could almost be long yeah I
felt like that Blanc and maybe something
like read and Stimpy or something where
you know you could go over the top like
that but I that's probably my only
complaint I honestly thought the rest of
the animation was really solid yeah for
the most part it looked you know I think
honestly I think it could have used an
even bigger budget um I honestly for
what we got I thought looked really good
like those city doesn't let everything
look trim I have an older goal I thought
it looked good I mean maybe this is
because we're looking at this now with
hindsight being 20/20 and we've got all
the films out now um but I bet some of
the animators I just feel like it's like
if that's what they could do with what
they were given I'm like add 20 more
minutes of animation cut the live-action
stuff and give them a bigger budget I
mean this could been really incredible
looking yeah like I I just I think it's
pretty good-looking honestly if there
was a movie that I would like to see
remade this would be it I would totally
if you do like a either 2d or I could
see this easily as a CGI film
considering all like yeah the parts of
the body inside like cut the live
actions of like
I think it would be really entertaining
if you're gonna remake a movie which I
generally don't endorse but cuz this one
had so many problems to begin with I'm
like he's not like makes a better
perfect for that but but you got a good
idea with you know with the pill and and
the white blood cell having a team I you
know it's a funny idea and really
educational yeah oh yeah yeah actually
is and I think you could do it with like
an edge where it's like we're either
gonna really make fun of these cliches
or we're not gonna do we're gonna do
something really clever just trying to
stop the disease you know and not do
anything other stuff uh and yeah no I
I'm coming with you I think it would be
an interesting remaking there's a lot of
actors you could cast and redo it with
you that's always my whenever people are
like look the remaking drop dead Fred
what do you think I'm like good we make
bad movies we make bad movies that have
awesome don't look at that again because
these people who like drop dead Fred but
no no okay well I mean even the people
it's pretty really oh yeah well this is
like when we're talking about the suits
films a quill some people like Cat Man
I'm like really yeah there's some people
like drop it huh oh hello such a yeah
I love the actors I just think they were
terrible in that movie but ya know the
actors are good but uh uh but no but
that's always so I'm saying if they're
saying like the rebooting our
wheatfields kids what do you think about
that it's like if there's a good idea
there that was botched
please redo it fix the problem no no I
don't think we need to dig up Garbage
Pail Kids ever I mean I don't see the
point but I hope within game ever the
worst movie and I've ever seen
don't do it again I don't see how you
can hang your word but I don't see how
you can make a movie out of a year you
don't see how they can make it worse you
know with the fact that you ask that
means it's theoretical to try emergency
being with it well um so yeah I miss the
bottom line we don't and we don't hate
this way we almost kind of liked it ah
the anime of origins that way I liked
the animated stuff yeah it was just a
card your phone this time hahaha you
turn it off this step um there we go but
uh yeah it was not realize my phone was
in um but yeah it's a it's not the worst
it's nowhere even near like any of the
time
or anything it's like almost enjoyable
but yeah the live-action stuff the
cliches and some of the lack of comedy
even in the animation stuff it's kind of
like I don't come out you can do this
better
um but yeah it's like I was there's
partial we were watching the film it's
like we weren't even say anything like I
just I kind of sucked into this world
yeah out there that's annoying it looks
I'm actually just enjoying the movie for
what it is that's that happens so rarely
yeah
Kent takes us by shine we're either like
quiet because the films give me so
little to work with in a good way or a
bad way
oh yeah bad way we're going because
we're just bored yeah but a good way
because I do the last one we did yeah
but ah I supposed to John's no just
quiet cuz it was like it was pretty
decent animated film yeah like it almost
works um but uh yeah that's our thoughts
on that and we will see you at the next
one like that